quels sont les points communs entre
serena williams et moi
non malheureusement c'est pas salaire ni
le nom d'un grand chelem en fait je suis
vraiment pas bon tennis le premier point
en commun si nous sommes plus deux des
athlètes
le deuxième point commun propose étonné
en fait c'est un peu tous les deux
végétalien
je traite est professionnel et un ultra
marathonien et je suis végétarien depuis
plus de dix ans
la différence entre le végétalisme
helvète à risque si on ne peut pas
manger de viande ne mange pas de
produits laitiers une produits dérivés
d'animaux comme les oeufs et le miel
le végétalisme si beaucoup plus qu'une
diète c'est un mode de vie un mode de
vie qui m'a permis d'atteindre meilleur
niveau dans sport
la raison pourquoi je suis devenu
végétarien puis par la suite vers
italien si j'ai vu par hasard un court
vidéo de cruauté animale sur twitter
après seulement quelques secondes le
visionnement j'aime également décidé d
arrêter de manger la viande
j'exige était hypocrite gec ge aimait
les animaux mais je manger du steak ou
super
vraiment le plus gros paradoxe
on aime les animaux on aimait manger
les animaux comme les humains veulent
deux choses soit éviter la souffrance et
être heureux
par contre la façon que l'on élève les
animaux nos jours à contactant des
centaines de bétail à côté de l'autre
raleigh ces deux choses une vie aux
rimes et son bonheur
l'ebit sont séparés leur mère dès la
naissance et leur mort est atroce
leur seule raison de vivre et de grossir
le pire allemand posthume prend ensuite
été tuées et est mangée
donc la fin raison proches devenus vegan
c'est pour l'aspect éthique
mais par après j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser à l'aspect écologique des
lamentations vegan
et s'enferre résille à quel point manger
de la viande n'est pas écologique
selon l'organisation de l'alimentation
il a effectué des nations unies
l'élevage de bétail responsable de 18%
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre
soit encore plus que les voitures
mais en plus de polluer l'élevage de
bétail les ide beaucoup de ressources
passe rarement beaucoup d'eau et
beaucoup de nourriture
sont un comité pour la science dans
l'intérêt public
55 % la consommation d'eau détenus aux
états unis si pour l'élevage du bétail
et selon la banque mondiale lavage de
bétail et responsable jusqu'à 91 % la
destruction de l'amazonie
si statistiquement grandement
bouleversée
sûr mais toujours que je considérais
comme quelqu'un d'écologique je me
promène à vélo anna les longues qu'on me
rends pas mes entraînements ou
université où je prends le transport en
commun j'ai réussi que je composte j'ai
une ma consommation d'un triste et je
prends même des douches courte je crois
et donc je ferai tout en mon possible
pour réduire le plus possible mon
empreinte écologique
par contre j'ai réalisé que j'en faisais
pas assez et qu'aucune personne puisse
considérer comme éco responsable si elle
mange la viande la même façon qu aucune
personne qui ont dû à un mur puisque on
serait comme écologique seulement parce
qu'il est classique fait du compost
le souvent l'impression de sentir
impuissant veut faire changer les choses
rendre le monde meilleur réduire la
souffrance la planète
on dit que seuls ont pu rien faire et on
se plaint que le gouvernement fait pas
grand chose pour l'environnement par
contre à chaque jour on prend une
décision qui n'est pas qu'un homme sur
notre santé sur la planète et sur la vie
d'êtres vivants
à chaque fois qu on ouvre le frigo ou
qu'on va les pousser on prend une
décision soit manger de la viande ou
manger des plantes et cette décision a
un impact énorme manger des plantes est
un choix éthique un choix écologique un
choix bons problèmes de santé
qui aurait cru que le tofu la luzerne et
un si gros impact sur la planète
la raison pourquoi je suis ici
aujourd'hui c'est pas pour vous parler
du côté négatif de manger de la viande
mais plutôt pour montrer comment manger
plus de fruits et légumes légumineuses
pour permet d'être en meilleure santé et
de mieux performer
mon but donc de démystifier tout
limitons la vega nice devait montrer
qu'on peut appeler un athlète de haut
niveau sans manger de viande
le premier mythe sais que c'est
impossible de consommer assez de
calories sans manger de viande
je crois que c'est un très bon exemple
que si ce n'est pas seulement possible
mais c'est très facile
je fais des ultramarathons et je fais
des triathlons ironman
on a vraiment c'est quoi ces trois
points 8 km de natation 180 km de vélo
et comme ce n'était pas assez on termine
avec un marathon
c'est 8 eur pour les meilleures heures
et jusqu'à 17 heures pour les amateurs
ça représente huit à dix mille calories
ou en nombre de bananes 112 banane
à chaque jour je m'entraîne deux ou
trois fois par jour et cela représente 4
à 6000 calories
donc évidemment je mange pas juste du
tofu plus d'illusions
en fait toutes les places t'endors
peuvent être légalisés sacs soient des
tacos la lasagne des plats asiatiques
des burgers ou même super calzones et
voyez c'est pas mal moins plate que vous
pensiez n'est ce pas
un deuxième but si c est possible de
consommer à cette protéine en mangeant
sans manger de viande
et samut promet une autre obsession par
les protéines
évidemment les protéines ce maquereau
nutriments essentiels
mais la majorité des gens consomment
déjà trou dans leur que d'horreur
alimentation et en plus on consomme et
d'échec des protéines des bords de
protéines en espérant qu'un hommage de
façon magique savoir donner des muscles
premièrement lorsqu'on parle de
protéines on devrait plutôt parler
d'acides aminés soit les petits blocs de
lego qui forment les protéines
les aliments comme les légumineuses leur
île et légumes contiennent toutes ces
petits blocs de lego donc en suivant une
alimentation variée on accumule toutes
ses côtés ces acides aminés et on forme
aux protéines dans notre corps
par contre que les gens ne réalisent pas
si les protéines végétales sont beaucoup
plus faciles à digérer les protéines
animales
quand je mange de la viande je mangeais
un gros dîner avec tant de viande 100
prenait des heures et des heures à
digérer je me sentais léthargique après
le dîner donc au lieu de prendre mon
énergie pour après les entraînements je
la prenais pressé de récup et de dj
raymond dîner
maintenant quand je mange un dîner léger
comme du quinoa des légumineuses ça me
rend vraiment pas beaucoup de temps pour
digérer et je peux m'entraîner tout de
suite après
nous appartient de l'obsession par les
protéines ont négligé un nutriment très
important soit les fibres en fait - trop
pour cent des américains mangent à 6 du
film et ne fabriquer sur dix ne respecte
pas les recommandations concernent la
quantité de légumes à manger à chaque
jour
si on mangeait plus de plantes donc plus
de films ont pré combler ce manque de
fibres qui a fait une population qui est
une des causes des problèmes d'obésité
d'hypertension de diabète de type 2 les
problèmes cardiovasculaires et même de
certains cancers
moi j'ai plus de plantes donc plus de
films permet de demeurer notre vote est
restée roll d'améliorer notre société à
l'insuline nous aider à perdre du poids
et maintenir un poids santé et d'avoir
un bon microbiome folie bactéries dans
notre corps
manger une puce de plantes dont plus de
films et donc la solution pour les
problèmes de santé de nos populations
un autre mythe segment jv games et très
coûteux par contre quand on regarde le
panier d'épicerie d'une personne
omnivore les produits les plus chers
sont souvent la viande le poisson et les
fruits de mer occupant la viande on
sauve donc beaucoup d'argent
les aliments base de plantes et les
aliments comme le riz les légumineuses
et légumes sagement les aliments les
moins chers puisque les gens dans les
pays plus pauvres consomment à chaque
jour
un dernier mythe si quand la viande et
produits dérivés d'animaux de notre
alimentation on resterait civ4 immense
qu'on peut manger
mais en fait c'est tout le contraire en
faisant la transition vers le vegalis
j'ai vraiment peu l'impression de me
sentir limitée au contraire j'ai
découvert plein de produits j'ai essayé
plein de nouvelles recettes et j'ai
appris à aimer à cuisiner et à
expérimenter dans la cuisine
mon alimentation est vraiment plus
intéressante et variée maintenant il mon
frigo est rempli de fruits et légumes de
toutes les couleurs
mais au bout mon but aujourd'hui c'est
pas du convient d'être vegan ni même me
sentir mal de manger la viande
ce que je souhaite si vous ignorez un
peu votre la surconsommation de viande
et vous manger plus de fruits de légumes
et légumineuses
s'il veut convaincre chacun d'entre vous
demandez mans j'y vais j'ai une journée
par semaine ça signifie une diminution
de votre consommation de viande de 14%
et ses problèmes beaucoup plus facile de
convaincre chacun d'entre vous de
diminuer votre consommation de viande de
14% que de convaincre 14 personnes à la
salle de devenir complètement vegan
et c'est ce qui risque d'avoir le plus
gros impact parce que si vous décidez de
manger vais gérer leur dise qu'on
appelle les lundis vg vous allez bien
vous sentir vous avez appelé l'énergie
vous allez aimer la bouffe vegan langue
est fort probable que vous avez passé
deux jours vg à deux jours puis à trois
jours aussi vrai sûrement parler à vos
amis à votre famille
c'est comme ça que je crois comprendre
le plus gros impact sur les adjuvants
sur votre santé et sur la planète
je préfère vous donnez vous permettent
de développer lentement mais sûrement de
nouvelles habitudes de vie qu'ils
puissent rester le plus longtemps
possible
voici donc mes trucs pour égaliser votre
vie
mon premier truc c'est le temps passé de
façon positive donc lorsque vous allez à
l'épicerie au lieu de vous dire
aujourd'hui faujas et d'en manger moins
de viande ou plutôt aujourd'hui j'ai
goûté à du nouveau substitut de viande
ça peut être dû te fugue tempo des
ligues mineures ou même les substituts
viande quand wg ou du faux couleurs
dans le même état d'esprit
lorsque vous préparez une assiette
essayer d'augmenter de plus en plus la
proportion votre assiette qui est des
plantes dans le but de surcharger votre
site de plantes jusqu'à ce que la viande
occupe une place de moins en moins
grosse dans votre assiette
aussi comme j'en ai parlé
fait commencer par une journée par une
journée vj par semaine est le lundi
c'est la journée parfaite lorsque vous
débutez la semaine le lundi donc si une
bonne façon de diviser la semaine du bon
pied ou si vous préférez fait débuter
par repas de la journée et
personnellement je trouve le repas le
plus facile à légaliser c'est le
déjeuner parce que la majorité des gens
mangent déjà levé geoghegan déjeuner par
exemple si manger des toasts au beurre
d'arachide manger déjà vegan déjeuner
sans même vous en rendre compte vous
voyez c'est pas si compliqué si vous
mangez des serial ou du gris au clavier
remplacer le lait de vache par du lait
de plantes comme de l'extérieur ou du
lait d'amande
un autre conseil que j'ai pas sûrement
pour les gens qui aiment beaucoup le
goût de la viande c'est profiter de tous
les substituts viande qui existent qu en
oubliant demi tout impossible foule ces
produits sont disponibles maintenant
tous les épiceries et non plus en plus
de restaurants et de fast food
une bonne façon de remplacer la viande
par un produit que le même vous la même
texture - une grosse mais moins de gras
saturés
aussi c'est vraiment facile de
convaincre vos amis amateurs de viande
de manger un burger vegan qu'elle
essayait de goûter à une galette de
tempo puis fort probable que cette
personne les amateurs de viande vont
être plus tentés a commencé à incorporer
de plus en plus de produits vg dans son
alimentation
c'est ce que j'aime la creuse et films
derrière ces produits si au lieu de cet
exercice on dit si on veut pas vendre le
plus de gens ne mangent ivg repas ça m'a
créé un produit similaire la viande on
veut créer un produit que le même goût
mais qui est meilleur pour la santé
c'est un peu comme la philosophie de
tesla
aux luttes seulement créer une autre
voiture électrique ils sont dix recrues
une voiture est tellement de gadgets
tellement technologie que même les gens
qui sont pas réellement préoccupés par
l'environnement qui aurait jamais pensé
conduire une voiture électrique vont
être super excité par cette voiture
c'est ce que j'aime de ses compagnes et
de ses produits et ce en plus ma
philosophie je vais rendre les gens que
je côtoie et vous dans la salle excités
par les plantes
je vous sorti de la salle ce soir vous
dirigez votre voix votre épicerie pour
vous acheter du brocoli
bref
j'ai pas là pour faire la morale je mène
pas là pour vous convaincre des vegan
tout ce que je souhaite de vous rendre
excité à l'idée de cuisiner de voix que
lui ce soir
merci
[Applaudissements]